[Music]
esmeralda is going to start off this
hour in fresno hi esmerelda how are you
hi guys i'm glad i get to talk to both
of you
better than i deserve what's up okay so
i'm kind of like corruptional nurse and
um
i get paid pretty well for what i do
just because of the environment that i
work in
um
and my goal is to become a school nurse
which actually got the position and i
should start soon
but i'm definitely going to take a pay
cut just because of the change of
environment and this is something that
i've been wanting to do for a very long
time because i'm just
stressed and overwhelmed and
the environment is just not the best to
work at
but
my
question is whether this is a good move
right now financially just because i
will be taking a pay cut how big of a
pay cut
it's about
15 thousand dollars a year what do you
make now
i make a hundred okay and you're gonna
cut to 85 and be a school nurse is that
what you said yes but then in about two
to three years i'll be back at 100. okay
well let's talk about what the next two
to three years looks like before that so
where does that put you are you single
income double income
um
double income my husband makes about 120
so
that's why he's not worried and he's
like you need to go for this if this is
something that you really want to do
because we're we have about
forty thousand dollars in debt so he's
willing to buckle down and pay all that
off that's awesome well you have a two
hundred thousand dollar income between
the two of you sure so this is just more
me and being scared of like hey you know
i went to school and got my rn and i
wanted to make 100 and i think it's just
more me taking like
the drawback of taking the pay cut yeah
can i suggest to you esmerelda it may
not be just you
part of this i wonder i wonder if you're
worried about what other people might
say or are already saying when you go
from rn and this you know that's
obviously a very prestigious role and
moving into school nurse i wonder how
much of that is coming from what you
think other people might think or say
i think
i don't think it's i think it's just me
if i had a goal of making a certain
amount and how i am and
with overtime here that the potential is
limitless but also i'm concerned with my
mental health and
obviously a little bit of safety because
it's getting a little out of control in
here at times i would say well esmeralda
you just laid out multiple reasons you
answered your own question as to why
this is the right move all of those
negatives are absolutely confirmation
that you need to move but the biggest
confirmation is that you've longed for
this you said i've wanted to do this for
a long time your husband is on board
that's a fantastic position to be in
financially this is not going to be that
big of a hit you're still going to pay
off that debt and you're going to be
happy and you're going to be fulfilled
and i understand where you're coming
from but you need to give yourself a
break because you have in fact achieved
that goal but what's great is you now
realize that that goal doesn't match up
with your heart and you got to follow
your heart here esmerelda step into this
this is a great move there's nothing
wrong with this move this is the right
move what's the uh what's the worst case
scenario you take the new job
and you get over there
and you hate it
and 20 seconds later you can be an rn
again in a hospital
oh no yeah i can finally so you're not
this is not a part this is not like uh
you burned all the boats and you can't
go back home
you know
so you you can do whatever you want to
do go try it
and if it doesn't work go back to being
an rn
in a less toxic environment some place
some other hospital some other situation
would be an rn at the school i know but
i'm saying go back into the medical
world rather than the school nurse world
and um if you don't like it if you like
it you know it it this is a no
lose scenario because you you can
in the world that you live in you can
get another job in 26 seconds if you
decide you don't want to be a school
nurse anymore after a year so do it
absolutely go
do it esmerelda